Elena Volochine vous êtes notre ancienne
correspondante à Moscou Prigogine doit
se rendre en Biélorussie selon le
porte-parole du Kremlin c'est une mise
en résidence surveillée c'est une
défaite en tout cas je pense que le
scénario de la retraite en Biélorussie
n'existe pas c'est à dire que c'est
quelque chose qui a été inventé par le
Kremlin tout comme la médiation
d'Alexandre lucaschenko même si ils se
sont parlés ce n'est certainement pas
Alexandre lucachenault co qui offre
l'asile il faut bien comprendre qu'il y
avait gagné Prigogine peut tout aussi
bien aller se retrancher dans sa tour
qu'il a fait construire à
Saint-Pétersbourg dans cette immense
immeuble devenu le QG de Wagner il peut
très bien aller sur une position à
l'arrière de l'arrière de la ligne de
front il peut très bien partir dans un
pays d'Afrique ceci est un leurre le
scénario est celui aujourd'hui vraiment
d'un film de fiction en 24 heures il y
avait gagné Prigogine entre en Russie
comme dans du beurre et avance avec une
colonne de blindée jusqu'à 200 km au sud
de Moscou Poutine qui déclare une
opération antiterroriste laisse avancer
cette colonne sur une route jusqu'à 200
km au sud de Moscou rappelons-nous de ce
qui se passe lorsque Vladimir Poutine
déclare des opérations anti-terroristes
Nord dos la prise d'otage en 2022 170
morts parmi les otages les civils
besslane 2004 333 morts dont des enfants
parmi des otages la Tchétchénie
c'est-à-dire que lorsqu'il y a une
opération antiterroriste avec cette
colonne de char sur Kiev rappelez-vous
la colonne de tancrus elle a été
bombardée là il arrive quand même très
très loin et puis tout d'un coup toutes
les poursuites sont abandonnées il a
l'immunité alors qu'il est déclaré
terroriste numéro un traître numéro 1 et
là surgit Alexandre le cachenko le
vassal de Vladimir Poutine et l'invite
en Biélorussie le scénario est
complètement surréaliste mais qu'il soit
en Afrique qu'ils doivent partir en
Afrique ou en Russie où vous dites en
tout cas il est vaincu sa tentative de
putscha raté pour le moment alors il est
vaincu oui si tentait que il était
réellement
dans l'initiative où il a prétendu être
aujourd'hui on ne peut faire que poser
des questions et de se mettre des
scénarios sur la table presque un auteur
de fiction pour imaginer ce qui a
réellement pu se passer en coulisses les
deux vraies questions sont celles du
vrai et du faux je vous ai fait les
hypothèses qui démontent le fait que
tout ceci aurait été vrai maintenant on
peut aussi dire que le fait que c'était
une fausse opération et tout aussi
surréaliste parce que il trigogne quand
même
mener à une situation
prendre autant de risques dire que
mettre en cause ce qu'il a mis en cause
y compris indirectement Vladimir Poutine
dans ses vidéos pour avoir pillé la
région du dombases pour être un clan
d'oligarque au pouvoir etc enfin il est
quand même aller très loin est-ce qu'il
a juste débordé dans un scénario on
l'avait mis je vous le dis il n'y a
aujourd'hui que des questions en tout
cas pour moi il faut garder en tête
plusieurs choses essentielles c'est que
il ne faut pas faire confiance à la
version du Kremlin qui dit que toutes
toutes les poursuites sont levées contre
prigogines il y aura l'impunité il se
retire en Biélorussie juste un mot sur
la Biélorussie parce que c'est très
important c'est le territoire qui au fil
des ans depuis les accords de 99 signés
par yel synagonisant qui transmettait le
pouvoir aboutine et lucaschenko déjà au
pouvoir depuis ces accords la
Biélorussie a deux faites été intégrées
à la Fédération de Russie c'est un
espace unique c'est presque un état
informel de la Fédération de Russie
parmi les États qui la composent donc
dans ce cadre-là
la Biélorussie est en quelque sorte
l'anti chambres noires de la guerre en
Ukraine et il peut s'y passer tout et
n'importe quoi sans qu'on ne sache c'est
juste une base arrière et donc c'est
cette location a servi d'intermédiaire
je n'en rajoute que c'est la je ne pense
pas qu'il a servi d'intermédiaire je
pense qu'il sert de vassal il fait ce
qu'on lui dit de faire en tout cas
aujourd'hui il faut faire disparaître il
y avait gagné le Prigogine ça c'est
clair mais pas physiquement il faut le
faire disparaître médiatiquement tout
comme il est apparu puisque il était
invisible on le rappelle jusqu'à il y a
quelques mois à peine et d'ailleurs il
est resté invisible les chaînes de
télévision russe nous l'ont pas montré
hier ils l'ont juste mentionné et c'est
l'une des premières fois où ils
prononçait son nom c'est-à-dire que
voilà il y a le game il est sorti de
l'ombre et il va y retourner la
Biélorussie je le disais une antiche
chambre noire c'est une bonne plante
maintenant le rôle réel de yefghani
Prigogine qu'est-ce qu'il a fait avec
tout ça on l'ignore qu'est-ce qu'il va
devenir après tout ça on l'ignore aussi
c'est pour ça qu'il part en Biélorussie
mais donc est-ce qu'il va prendre plus
d'importance sur le front des opérations
est-ce qu'il va devenir un commandant
informel qui va avoir plus de succès que
l'état-major qu'il met en cause est-ce
que parce que là ce que nous dit le
Kremlin c'est les hommes de Wagner
retournent sur les positions mais il y a
gagné prigognes disparaît en Biélorussie
c'est quand même vraiment concrètement
que sa puissance a dépassait la
puissance de prix d'origine à dépasser
les hommes de Wagner alors la puissance
de prix goji n'a dépassé les hommes de
Wagner non trigogine et avec les hommes
il est avec ses amis des complicités
avec certains militaires par contre que
la puissance de prix d'origine a dépassé
le commandement militaire russe ça oui
ça c'est possible sachant que c'est les
services secrets militaires russes qui
ont créé vladim IR pardon qui ont créé
le yorking et la ministre privée Wagner
la vraie question c'est celle de savoir
où se situe la fissure parmi les
innombrables forces de sécurité qui
gouvernent la Russie aujourd'hui
derrière Vladimir Poutine et cette
fissure là quels sont les forces de
sécurité derrière Prigogine et qu'elles
sont celles qu'il défie C'est ça la
vraie question merci beaucoup Elena
bolochine pour votre analyse merci